a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe today go to spectator.com uk
forward slash tv offer well richie
sooner welcome to the offices of the
spectator
um thanks for having me uh the morning
after the night before uh exciting
debate last night um
just a preliminary um because you
mentioned it first in the in the debate
last night um david trumbull died and
you and you paid tribute to him
almost the last thing david trumbull
intervened on i think the last in public
life was on the northern ireland
protocol and he was very worried about
it because he said that um it threatened
the peace process it's threatened the
belfast
agreement um do you agree with that
well i think where i agree with david is
we must preserve the union and as i said
last night he was someone who did
enormous amount to support the union
bring peace to northern ireland and
we'll miss him dearly for that
and what i've seen in the job that i've
had is certainly economically
the the patterns of trade have changed
in a way that
moves northern ireland further away from
the orbit of the rest of the united
kingdom and that's not something that
i want to see continue and i think there
are some very real challenges with the
arrangements that are in place currently
i'd like to see those fixed and that's
why i think the protocol bill gives us
an opportunity to do that but the door
should always be there for a negotiated
settlement with with europe not least
because it is a lot faster it will take
time for that legislation to get through
all its stages in parliament and as
prime minister or whoever the new leader
is i think there will be an opportunity
to again talk to our irish and european
friends and see if we can find a
solution that is in everyone's interest
so you think um your opponents
line on this is um
a bit hyper and you don't you don't
worry about the political dangers in
northern ireland
no i mean i i do i do worry about the
impact that the protocol is having on
the ground absolutely and i see that
from businesses i see that from
disrupted trade flows and that that
speaks to a broader thing it's not just
about the the fact that trade is being
disrupted we care about the territorial
integrity i care about the territorial
integrity of our united kingdom and if
we've got a set of processes in place
currently
that are undermining that
then i don't think that's something that
any uk prime minister could accept and
but obviously i would want to find ways
to correct that the bill gives us the
opportunity to correct those it will
take time to get through parliament so
if there's an opportunity for a
negotiator settlement i think any prime
minister of course should look at that
not least because it could be could be
far quicker resolution to those issues
but i think we must be clear that there
is there is genuine
there is genuine
forces here that are undermining the
union and it's right that we look at
them and address them and fix them
thank you um
let's go to the debate uh more widely um
i don't want to spend all the time
talking about the debate but it's a good
focus for where we've got to in this um
uh why was the i mean the jolly well it
was different last night and there was
why is there no more mr nice guy why is
it all changed like that
well half the time people are saying to
me well we're not sure if you can be
tough enough if you're tough enough to
be a prime minister and then and then
when you when you are tough it's all
good you're too tough no we don't like
that no i think you know i think these
ideas really matter to me and
i'm i'm saying the things that i believe
are in the best interest of our country
you know i'm in this because i believe
in public service
and i've deliberately chosen to say some
things that probably aren't that easy
they're certainly not doing me any
favors as you can see but i firmly
passionately believe that the right
things for our country and that's why
i'm going to keep saying them and i'm
going to keep talking about them
passionately and i think it's right that
everyone engages with these with these
questions and i'm sure we're going to
get into it now we are but um
the the word it wasn't invented solely
by liz truss's people i got a text from
a friend who was watching saying he's
mansplaining
um what what do you what do you say to
that
i think these these are just vigorous
debates on
policy and i think it's right that
that each of us are held to account by
the other for the the things that we're
saying and that proper scrutiny is
brought to bear on those i'm you know
i'm passionate about these things
because i'm genuinely
worried about the potential direction of
travel for the country if we do things
that will damage people's livelihoods
push up mortgage rates and i care deeply
about that so even if it's not going to
be easy for me i want to have that
debate and i'm going to make sure that
we but i thought we liked you because
you were such a scrupulously polite
person and you were a little bit rude
last night weren't you
i don't know i don't think i was rude i
was just making sure that the the points
that needed to be debated were heard
very good i am and i've got nothing but
enormous personal affection and regard
for liz as i think everybody knows and
we've worked together for a long time
and this is not about her as a person or
me as a person this is about
this is about the ideas that we're
trying to debate on that actually um and
you you both sort of brought that quite
pleasantly together at the end uh in the
debate but do you regret
that
the frame the form of all of this so
that you are
sort of invited to attack one another in
public yes i do so would you do it
differently well i think it's very well
it's just it's fundamentally quite hard
i mean it's a hard thing to reconcile if
you want to have
a debate with two people head to head on
live tv
you know it's unfortunately going to
accentuate the differences the format
that's what the format is designed to do
and there's a balance to be struck by
making sure that the process
is accountable to the general public
because we're also picking a prime
minister
but having a process that actually
reminds everyone we're all on the same
team here we're all conservatives as i
was at pains to point out last night
we're on the same family and we'll come
together after this to serve the british
people
you know
there's a debate to be had about what's
the right way to provide that scrutiny
and accountability but also do so in a
way that is supportive of our
conservative family i think there's
probably a question to be had about that
yes because i think at this point we're
having more more election debates than
we've had in the general election
campaign
and we're only we're only we're only a
week into it yes i mean um in your maze
lecture this year um you praised um paul
romer at the i think he's a stanford
professor he is well he was when i was
yeah he taught what he told me yes for
the um for the concept of non-rivalrous
ideas
it wasn't much
showing of that last night was there
uh
no i mean although i mean this is the
thing it's great that you read the
lecture so thank you charles so he was
my professor at stanford and he's won a
nobel prize for economics and
what was inspiring about him was he
talked about where does growth come from
in a modern economy yes and and actually
this is a problem with these debates as
they're actually on an incredibly narrow
set of topics and that's actually
something i'm sad about we didn't really
get a chance to talk about growth very
much last night you read my lecture
which is good of you but that is a very
detailed
thoughtful i would say view of how to
drive growth in a 21st century economy
and i set out i set out my view on that
and it's based on my values
as a conservative and a belief in free
enterprise as the as the best way to
drive that growth
but it's also based on my experience in
business and my understanding of the
very real challenges that we face and
paul roma's idea was about innovation
yes and actually a 21st century economy
the most important way to drive growth
is by having an economy that is able to
create new ideas and then spread them
across the rest of the economy and it's
something that we used to be very good
at we're still pretty good at it but we
need to make sure that we're the best
place in the world for it and my
particular experience in business living
and working internationally
means that i believe i'm the best place
person to lead us into the future and do
all the things that are necessary to
drive growth in the 21st century which
is about far more than tax cuts in the
tax system there's so many other things
we need to get right access to talent
making sure businesses have the capital
they need making sure our education
system is fit for the future we didn't
wear any of that last night which is sad
no but you could have but you chose i
think it quite often happens in in the
political debates that
you both of you
make a big thing of something that
actually probably isn't a first order
question and and that's i thinking away
what you've just been saying so um there
is a difference between you and liz
dress about tax cuts but
actually
that's not the big thing is it
well yeah and even on that i'm not you
know i think the difference is probably
accentuated because it it makes for good
tv i'm a conservative i believe in tax
cuts i believe in a lower tax economy i
mean anyone who's read anything i've
ever written or heard any of my speeches
that i've given
can see that and
of course i'm going to deliver tax cuts
and i actually set out earlier this year
i stood at the dispatch box and held up
a big
document that said tax plan on it with a
with the direction of travel for where
we're going to take business taxes and
personal taxes now i know no one's
particularly focused on that now but
those are the things i believe and
that's what i deliver as prime minister
i think there is a difference between us
because i think there is enormous risk
right now
in launching on a
a huge spree of borrowing funded tax
cuts that obviously don't pay for
themselves so really we are putting that
on the country's credit card to the tune
of tens of tens of billions of pounds i
don't think that's right morally but i
also think that that runs the risk of
entrenching inflation for longer and
driving up interest rates uh that was
what i was pointing out last night
that is the difference people will have
their own view on that i've made my
point of view clear on that
but as i said
last night we didn't talk about the nhs
we didn't talk about how to grapple the
backlogs which is actually one of the
most pressing public service priorities
we didn't talk about education and
actually our children's education today
is our economy tomorrow we didn't talk
about that we didn't talk about how to
tackle illegal migration i set out a
very detailed 10-point plan i put out a
video which i'd urge or spectator uh you
know viewers and readers if you've got
five minutes go on my website find that
video so you'll hear from me about
immigration i think there's your
advertisement well there you go but i
think those are all really pressing
issues as well and we didn't cover any
of them now i think in the probably
whatever three or four debates that
we've had so which is which is i think
sad for everybody so that being so um
despite the strong disagreement
if you win you'd be perfectly happy to
make liz trust your chance of exchequer
well i don't think it would be
appropriate for me to sit here and start
talking i'm not saying you have to i'm
just saying you'd be happy but as you
heard from me last night i mean again
i've got an enormous amount of
warmth and affection for liz and when i
first came to parliament
you know i was part of a group of mps
that all worked on very similar policies
together
together with liz and we served in
cabinet together
you know we do disagree on this and
that's fair enough and as i said i've
made my point she'll make her point
people will make up their their own mind
but it would be nice to to talk about
some of these other things uh as in the
course of the debates but with regard to
her and actually all the other
leadership candidates whether it's kemi
or all the others what you saw was gosh
there's an enormous amount of quality
and talent at the top of the
conservative party and you know part of
being a leader is bringing the party
back together i certainly would draw on
all the talents and traditions that our
parliamentary party has to build a team
of the best and the brightest and make
sure that everyone feels their point of
view is represented somewhere in
government the challenges that our
country faces at the moment are too
great not to put our best team forward
and you saw a lot of it on display in
this leadership debate when you um
now here is something in the economic
debate which you sort of did have but
you again you had it in quite a
a rough way um and it's both important
technically economically and it's
important politically and it really
centers on interest rates um you had a
big go at patrick minford though you
didn't name him um
as uh and you quoted him
he thinks in it in the times today
rather unfairly on um what he really
thinks about interest rates and what
they should be and so on um
but surely the fundamental issue here is
important and maybe
minford and maybe liz trust uh are right
if this is what they're saying that
low interest rates have actually been
very damaging for the western world
um and um
and that
it's been a sort of
government and central bankers working
together to in a way that has um
stopped
the growth of real wages um you know
inflated assets um uh
misdirected capital um
and
is really
cause inflation is really one of the big
problems of our time
and actually we need
higher interest rates we
obviously important debate about how
fast it should go but we do need them
don't we we
do you agree with those causations well
no but if if that is the view
then
all i'm saying is that we should just be
honest about that right what is your
view
my view is i worry about the impact of
significantly higher interest rates that
would be caused by a government
borrowing tens of billions of pounds at
a time when we already have an inflation
problem
because i think
unnecessarily making them even higher
would be very damaging for millions of
british families people with mortgages
businesses that are using loans to grow
their businesses and
your point of view not your point of
view but that point of view may well be
entirely reasonable but then it should
be then put on the table and if you're
going to say i'm going to go and borrow
lots of money i'm going to do all these
things
that will mean higher interest rates
that person might think that's a good
thing but at least they should be honest
about that so then people can make up
their mind as to whether they think that
that combination actually is better for
them
as i said
you know i think the the risk and it
wasn't me that said this it was it was
patrick minford who was the person that
liz quoted as the economist who was
supportive of her plan
who
mentioned the seven percent interest
rate it wasn't me it was it was him and
people should know what that means and
that means probably about six grand on a
typical morning well he didn't he didn't
say
he was talking about what might
ultimately be quite a good stage for
affairs which you have two percent
inflation but he did say
when to ask about the plan and doing
extra borrowing now he did very clearly
say interest rates would need to rise
yes and he very clearly gave some
numbers but they will need i mean they
will they are rising and they do and
they do need to write in the question
the question they're not attacking the
fact they're rising yeah of course i
mean i have support of
a central bank acting as i've told them
to act forcefully to control inflation
so
and that's what i did as as chancellor
there's a question about doing things
that make their job even harder yes
absolutely and make the situation even
worse and and beyond that it's if if
inflation gets entrenched in the system
then
what you need to do to get it out again
is very damaging and we've lived through
that as a country in the past and i know
you know there's now a generation of
people who have not lived through that
you know myself included i was born in
1980 it's not if i have lived experience
as an adult of it sure yeah obviously
i've i've studied economics so i
understand it but there'll be lots of
people who remember what that was
actually like yes
and
it writes and it's you know
the inflation genie when it gets out of
the bottle it's hard to put it back that
that really is true but we have to drill
this a bit harder because um one of the
criticisms of you it's to do with your
partner to do it is your part your own
fault for being such an extremely able
well-educated person is that um you tend
to
express with great um sort of clarity
and moderation what is basically the
orthodoxy and the orthodoxy has gone
wrong and one of the big orthodoxies is
all related to quantitative easing the
role of central banks um the role of
interest rates and how that's actually
not increase the general prosperity it's
increase the prosperity of people with
assets and um
the reason we've got inflation uh
one of the reasons we got inflation is
that there was yet more quantitative
easing very recently as well as what had
happened before
and the
central bank mandate that liz
trust was questioning
is problematic isn't it because all it
looks at is inflation
but actually you know
interest rates affect the economy rather
than just reflect reflecting it
and um uh and um
you know that's something that has so
for example shouldn't the mandate
include
watching asset prices
no i i think this i get this a lot this
question about orthodoxy and it's
interesting because
the orthodoxy was actually not that long
ago the interest rates would remain low
for a long time yeah and inflation no
one had to worry about right and we were
entering a period of secular stagnation
yeah that was the orthodoxy that was
indeed the orthodoxy in this country as
well as in the us and i was told by lots
of people
that it was okay borrowing was all right
you don't have to worry about that
anymore because interest rates will be
low forever
and
that was not
something i believed i i was one of the
first people
to say no i think that is wrong that
orthodoxy i think it's misguided and it
would be irresponsible as me
of me as chancellor to rely on that
sustaining and i actually said that i
said it early and then i said it again
in an interview with your with your
magazine and there's a great uh i think
there's a great front cover of the
spectator when i was doing an interview
with fraser and kate about this i think
way back when which was one of the first
times someone had actually talked about
it so that was me railing against this
orthodoxy at the time
so i think this idea that somehow i i
think is actually just not quite right
actually so i was the one who called
this out as a risk and you said earlier
in this interview that um you you told i
think you i told the bank uh to behave
because part of the job of chancellor is
to set the remit for the bank of england
and
part of my job is to do that and i did
that are you dissatisfied with what the
bank did
no
my job is to give them the remit their
job is to meet it now they're not alone
in grappling with high inflation so
us europe the us all of us have
inflation running close to double digits
actually so it's but there were some
particular things in the uk that i said
i was worried about some months ago yeah
one of them was inflation expectations
yes and actually that is a real
challenge because if people's
expectations of future inflation start
to rise that's where you get all the
challenges with wage price spirals yes
and you are starting to see that in the
uk ahead of other countries and that is
something that i want to make sure the
bank of england are cited on which they
are and it's something that i mentioned
in my conversations with the governor
and i know that they look at that and
that's what we need to guard against so
i and that's what government needs to
guard against as well because if
government is going to do things that
don't give people the confidence that
inflation will actually come down it
then becomes a self-fulfilling
situation where it doesn't come down
because people are planning for it not
to and then demanding wage settlements
that are higher and then we end up in
this this problem lasting years yes and
causing families enormous misery
one thing you're very emphatic about
is importance of
getting the public finances under
control
but of course if you're to do that you
will have to cut because you've spent
more than anyone else ever um now i'm
sure you'll argue perhaps right that's
no fault of your own on that but
but that is the fact of the case so what
are you going to cut
so
this is really important to me and i
might use the word emphatic and it's
actually i again we're talking i think i
hope to a largely conservative
supporting audience i actually find it
really sad that i seem to be pushing
what is considered a minority opinion on
this i don't know how we've got
ourselves into a situation
where
kierstarma
and the labour party
are now able to attack conservative
candidates
as peddling the fantasy economics of
unfunded promises i mean that's the
language he's using right they're
talking about the magic money tree
but they're talking about us
when it comes to the magic money tree
and i mean everyone just needs to take a
pause
and just think what has happened now
i i i was brought up with kind of
kitchen table conservative values yeah
you know when i was doing my mum's
accounts and her books
in our house for her local chemist that
she she ran that i worked in and and i
do believe that you have to pay for the
things that you spend money on that's a
kind of simple basic moral tenant of
conservatism i care about what we leave
our kids and our grandkids and i just
don't think it's right to rack up bills
on the country's credit card department
yes but then i'm also saying that we
should pay for those yes and not just
pass the buck on to them right but that
now seems to be something that no one
wants to face up to i think that's
really wrong and i don't you know i'm
not really bothered if people don't like
me saying it or it makes me unpopular i
deeply believe it to my core and you
know what if we are if we are not the
party of sound money i've said it before
like what is the point in the
conservative party it's the most
conservative of conservative values and
it's what i absolutely stand for so when
you invoke um mrs thatcher and you
you've done that including rather
germany photographically last weekend
that was my wife my wife was going to
literally she went slightly rogue
after that after that event when i
disappeared off to do whatever next
campaign stop yeah because she was there
with the kids and she thought well she
might might as well go and take them to
see this statue so which i didn't find
out about till much later in the evening
but yeah
but but so
what what's the essence
of the connection between rishi sunak
and margaret thatcher why does this
matter in order to fight this battle
today
i'm i'm not going to sit here and draw
the comparisons charles and you're
obviously the expert so i certainly
wouldn't try and do it with you but i
just know how i was raised and i i was
raised in the 80s i was born in 1980 and
i i was i was raised and it always felt
and we didn't talk politics at home my
parents didn't have time for that right
they were just working day and night
trying to make you know make a better
life for their three kids
and
but it was always the sense that
you know if you wanted to work really
hard
and build that better life for your
children that that was something that
she supported mrs thatcher right it was
that kind of middle class aspiration
that really struck a chord in my family
and i remember even later on when there
were some privatizations and my dad was
so excited and it wasn't huge money but
to make sure that there was a hundred
pounds worth of whatever privatized
utility or whatever it was at the time
and that was i remember that was a big
that was a big exciting thing when that
happened
in our house so it was that sense of our
values being aligned and of and of her
supporting families like ours to get on
and build a better life for themselves
that really struck a chord and then
later as i studied and learned and
everything else
you know her this kind of kitchen table
manager as i described it i i that
struck a chord with me you know you you
know she talked about her upbringing in
the grocery shop and all this this kind
of house yeah the the kind of approach
to the household budget that's how i was
raised
and so those values i think are quite
are quite similar to mine in that sense
and look on the policy side again you're
going to know better than me so i'm not
i'm not going to second-guess it but
i'm interested in how you'd write not
not trying to catch you out on her
that's what that's what spoke to me
about it at the time and
was she as you've seen her you've heard
from a bunch of people in her cabinet
you know whether that's lord howard or
lord and all these others and and peter
lily you know i'm so humbled to have the
support of people like that for the
approach i'm taking because they were
there with her yes and yes we all
remember those unbelievable tax cutting
budgets that nigel lawson delivered and
gosh you know that that was inspiring to
me and his memo on tax reform that is in
his biography you know i go and reread
and reread and reread because it's
brilliant um and i spoke to him about it
when i had the privilege of meeting him
but
you know we have to also remember what
jeffrey howe and her did at the
beginning yes and i quoted some of that
in my amazing lecture and there were
some real challenges that the country
faces and she was
she she did things that she didn't love
doing and she talked about it in her
memoirs but she knew they were the right
things to do for the country and then
that set the conditions for them to
deliver all the radicalism and i just
want to do the same yes um and here
there's a difficulty isn't there because
it sounds ridiculous to talk about her
as having
had some easy wins because she was
really difficult but um there were some
things she could do which you can't
because she's already done them so she
she got rid of the price commission she
got rid of exchange control she did the
trade union reforms she did
privatization uh and all of those things
and many others uh um
top rate attacks and things um
change the situation they did now
what can you do
because people are worried that they
know your heart's in the right place and
you know they know you've got a very
good head but they can't quite see the
path yeah so so this is
and this is the thing what is the
equivalent supply side radicalism for a
21st century economy yeah right and i've
thought long and hard about this and we
don't have those things you can't go and
privatize things to the same degree
can we be tougher on the unions of
course we can and we should legislate to
make sure that they have to have minimum
service standards and things but the top
rates of tax are not all 80 or 90
anymore and that's what i was saying
before growth in the 21st century is
about different things now right so the
supply side radicalism that i want to
bring is making sure that this is the
most productive innovative economy in
the world so that means making sure that
businesses invest because for far too
long businesses have not invested enough
so the tax cuts we need that i'm
proposing that i talked about in that
lecture were about tax cuts on business
investment because if you want to look
at where we're not competitive it's
there and if businesses don't invest in
equipment in manufacturing in production
in robotics we won't be able to create
better paid jobs of the future
the supply side activism we need is on
regulation in financial services post
brexit there's tons that we can reform
and i was about to introduce a bill as
chancellor that's a big bang 2.0 as i've
described it in the past and that will
unlock capital from our pension funds
and our insurance industry to drive
growing companies we need regulation
reform on clinical trials because life
sciences is one of the growth industries
of the future on how we use data on our
migration regime to make sure that the
best and the brightest from around the
world come and study and invent and
create companies here
we need free ports which i'm delivering
as a post-brexit opportunity to bring
jobs and investment to places like
t-side or southampton where i grew up or
homicide that those are all supply-side
radicalism for the 21st century they
look different to what she did but
people should be in no doubt that that
is the kind of radical change that i
want to bring yeah it looks different
but it's what is required in a 21st
century economy they are important um
and they would have real effects on real
people but um
compared with the thatcher era um they
are relatively
uh technocratic so um people used to say
um
i remember some taxi drivers and people
saying things like to me like maggie
thatcher got me my house right um now
what are they going to say about it what
did rishi's
do that was like that well if you go you
know if you walk around t side i'd like
to think they could say well you know
richie's doing help get me my job
because that i've got a job down the
freeport and i work in the vaccine
manufacturing plant that has opened
there or this new offshore wind
facility that ge have come and invested
in yeah and and that all happened
because he created this freeport here
and that that brought optimism and and
hope to us here but
the thing that the thing that really
should resonate with people is education
and that is the tangible thing there's
nothing technocratic about it it's a
thing that i'm most passionate about and
and my parents
you know they work day and night they
saved and they sacrifice because they
believe education was the path to a
better future for their children it's an
entirely conservative way of looking at
the world is how i look at the world and
i remember in my selection meeting
when they were asking me what job i
wanted i talked about the reforms that
michael gove had ushered in and how
i i had nothing but admiration for that
and it was inspiring to me and i wanted
to try and do something like that one
day if i was fortunate enough and that's
what we should be doing do you see a
particular thing to be done there i
think there's lots that we can do
because i think we've lost and part of
the
the
the
part of the
criticism may be a strong word but we've
been we had to deal with covid you know
i think we focused over the last few
years as a government a lot on well
let's how can we put more money into
public services and that's all good and
well we should be focused far more as
conservatives about what we get out of
public services
you know what how are we transforming
people's lives what are the reforms
we're doing which vested interest are we
taking on that's what michael did you
know he didn't have lots of extra money
he delivered all those can you do that
in relation to universities or schools
what you can do in schools
so in schools there's lots we can do you
know i i when i was working abroad i
volunteered with an educational charity
that worked with some of the toughest
state schools pretty much anywhere in
the world and we introduced technology
in a radical way into those scores and
it was brilliant the children's learning
improved teachers workload was freed up
entirely they could focus on what they
loved doing which was more personalized
learning for smaller groups of students
at a time and the kids were far more
motivated and engaged as a result and we
did that in some of the most deprived
areas that we were working in so there's
one simple one is this in the united
states this is in the states yeah where
i was doing that but we can bring that
same kind of radical thinking here as
well but curriculum is another area we
need to look at and i think again in a
21st century economy i think it's worth
us looking at have we got the balance
right between what we are doing at 16
and 18 and actually should we be looking
at things like
baccalaureates and other things where we
can have
no relaxation in our standards but a
broader set of subjects that prepare
students for the 21st century economy
and then we also need to double down on
teachers now you know i come from a
culture which absolutely reveres
teachers and teaching is one of the
noblest things that you can do
and that's what we need to make a
reality we need to get the best teachers
in the world here we need to give them
the support they need the training they
need
so that they can fulfill their potential
because that's what has the biggest
impact on kids now in doing all the
things i just mentioned there will be
lots like michael had there will be lots
of vested interests that rail against
all of those but as he showed when we
take on those things as conservatives
challenge convention push through good
reforms our children will benefit and
that's the type of very tangible thing
that we should and can be doing one of
the difficulties of this whole campaign
is that
there are these ambitions like that
which are very important but there's
such enormous immediate problems and one
of them is energy prices and um
this really does bring into question
net zero doesn't it because um
uh
it's one thing to say that you're very
wired about climate change and you and
you say that and you explain some some
remedies
but net zero as opposed to the question
of climate change is essentially an
arbitrary target invented by a sort of
international agreement the world isn't
going to change because something has
happened by 2050 particularly i mean do
you see what i mean and yet people are
now really really
squeezed on this and they're
really it's one of the major factors
that's costing them a lot more money and
also causing insecurity of supply you
must be worried about that aren't you
well i'm worried about the anxiety that
people are feeling right now with energy
bills of course i am i saw that but
specifically on the effect
of
why are we all chasing this thing when
when we've got this very urgent problem
well so i think we absolutely need to
deal with the urgent problem right and
and i said previously of course net zero
is important i think it's worth pointing
out that at this point i think 80 or
maybe even 90 percent of the world's gdp
is is covered by a net zero target and
it's quite fulfilled
no but no one is to fill them today
right these are all targets that are
happening in the future and
you know i've said very clearly that we
we shouldn't run at that target so hard
and so fast that we do enormous damage
to
people in the country along the way and
by the way we will then lose people we
will then lose people and actually
people will not want to do it at all so
we've got to do it in a measured way and
do it in a way that means that we you
know we're keeping pace but we don't
have to be the one out in front
necessarily so that's been my approach
to it the urgency of our problem now
you're right to highlight because it's
having a very real impact on people i
don't think you can blame that all on
that zero no let's be clear you know you
know russia started a war and we've
decided to take some action against that
and that's having an impact on energy
prices yeah so people absolutely need
support in the short term to help get
them through it but i think they're also
asking a question what is your long-term
solution here i've said that i'll have
an energy security target so you've
asked me about a net zero target
we should also have an energy security
target which i've said we will do before
2050 which means that we are energy
independent with energy whether that's
more offshore wind nuclear or new
sources we need to do that but it should
be an equal level of commitment
and in the short term the things that we
can do that will make a difference on
both are things like energy efficiency
which and fossil fuels that you you
because of the intermittency problem
that we need uh we need we absolutely
need we need more yeah and i i mean
i was i think the first cabinet minister
to
to actually again you feel like
challenging orthodoxy and everything
else i was the first cabinet minister to
go out and make a very positive
statement of support for the naughty oil
and gas industry
and i did that much earlier in this year
but you want the levies to stay you
don't agree with liz's thing of um
suspending the green levees
i think look this is just comes down to
borrowing right so that all those levees
pay for something so you can't magic
away the payments government has
contractual obligations on all of those
things so if someone is saying well
we're just going to not do them what
they're saying is we're just going to
borrow more yeah right i mean you can't
you can't you can't cancel the contracts
i think so those contracts are paying
for things that benefit people today
yeah and so you can perfectly well say
well we'll just borrow instead and not
have people pay for them but um
yeah can i go back um
i realized i thought i'd better have
another look at your resignation letter
and um because you know this ill
excitement it's all rather forgotten and
i actually don't understand why you
resigned
um
it doesn't say really um and when you
say um
well sorry so what's the answer to that
well
and boris is boris's letter also doesn't
in reply doesn't mention any
any disagreement so i'm sort of
slightly perplexed okay well i i'm not
as good a writer as you can so
so i apologize um
if i don't ever have to do that again
but next time i know i'll maybe
get some tips so there were two reasons
really which i thought came out in the
left or at least tried to the first was
about the conduct of government and
obviously
everyone will recall
the most recent in a long line of
incidents where trust was
called into question and that was over
the chris prencher thing now i've always
tried to give the promise of the benefit
of the doubt on these things when these
things have come up in the past but it
got to a point where enough was enough
for me and enough what
enough was enough on on
on it
on on questions of of trust right and
and and honestly about how we were
dealing so he was lying well i it's
unclear because exactly what happened
but it was clear to me that
what was said was not accurately
reflective of what seemed to have
happened so he wasn't telling the truth
well well he would say what his
spokesman said and
but at the end of the day look i
resigned right so
you can tell i wasn't comfortable with
it and i didn't want to defend it so at
some point me pretending otherwise i
didn't think how that situation played
out was appropriate and that's why i
resigned but the other proximate reason
was he and i were due to give a speech
about the economy and the direction of
travel and we were clearly on very
different pages as you can see in this
leadership election and and so um that's
on texas texas it's not just about tax
it was about again it comes back to
being honest with the country about the
challenges we face about how we grapple
them the responsible approach to dealing
with them yeah and and clearly so what's
the key to one thing you did say in the
letter which i said you didn't
understand is the public are ready to
hear the truth um what is the key truth
well i think well i think you've heard
it in this leadership election on the
economy i am prepared to say some things
that have not made my life easy
i'm prepared to tell people that you
can't have your cake and eat it yes
right uh you you can't actually and
that's and
that demolishes borism
yeah and we're seeing some of that
there's a lot of people who think you
can continue to do that right i think i
would argue that thinking that you can
borrow i think at last count 40 billion
pounds uh not do anything on public
spending and that will have no impact on
inflation or interest rates it feels to
me a little bit like cake-ism as well
yeah i i don't think that's leadership i
think leadership is about being honest
it's about acknowledging the trade-offs
involved in these very difficult things
and being
upfront about that and then being
responsible in how you deal with them
and part of the reason we're in the mess
we're in over the you know over the past
two years there has been too much of
that yes
and we need to get away from that and
that's the type of change in leadership
that i will bring as prime minister but
you were the chancellor so you
ultimately decide financial matters i i
know boris would say as promises do from
time to time i'm the first order of the
treasury but uh as far as the prime
minister decides
the prime minister decides right
the problem is your budget for example
it's my budget but the prime minister
has to sign off on the budget the prime
minister's right to the end of the day
that that's how it works and and i think
this has evolved over the years but you
know ultimately the prime minister
decides as well i'm obviously going to
give him
my view on what we should do and the
best advice that i can and clearly as
you could see
we that's why partly why i resigned
because it doesn't work
if the prime minister and chancellor are
not
very much on the same page yes on on the
economy in the direction of travel
particularly when things are going to be
challenging and
that's why i had to go at the end of the
day
and actually this had gone on quite a
lot before and you've been pretty i mean
did you just think quite seriously think
of residing before that quite often
i you know i i'm instinctively a loyal
person and i had an enormous
gratitude to the pm for giving me this
job and i'd like to think i did a good
job in it and had to do a budget in
record time after being appointed help
get the country through coronavirus and
i you know i'm proud of the things that
i achieved in the job working with him
and i always wanted to try and support
him and recognize and respect the fact
that he is a prime minister that won a
very significant majority
and you know if he stood on the steps of
downing street and said that he wanted
to fix and reform social care if he
wanted to deliver 50 000 nurses and 40
new hospitals and 20 000 more police
officers and level up across the country
that those commitments should be
delivered and you know my job was to
make that work and i tried to do that
for as long as i could um
but you say um
you you talk about loyalty but
well i'm i'm a bit puzzled by the whole
thing um when geoffrey howe
uh resigned his resignation letter made
absolutely clear it was all about europe
um
we're now in an odd situation which
we're asked to believe that um
you're the sort of
great decent honorable person
um but also um
uh you're the one who uh stabbed the
prime minister
and um
so people have rather conflicted views
about and this is particularly true of
um tory voters i think yeah i i can
appreciate that and
when i resigned as i said in that letter
i i resigned knowing it may well be the
last job
i ever had in government yeah and i'm
comfortable with that i resigned on
principle and principles matter to me
and if that means that this doesn't work
out for me so be it and i don't know i
will always sleep soundly at night
knowing that for me resigning was the
right thing to do because i couldn't
condone the conduct of government at
that moment and i couldn't take part in
an economic strategy that i didn't agree
with so i was left with no choice but to
act on my principles and i did i did the
same in the past with brexit i would do
the same again as prime minister because
principles mattered however you had made
provision that it wasn't very likely
you'd be straight out in the wilderness
because nothing was better organized
than your machine to go for the moment
you
resigned you know i
i actually enormous tribute to them
because we always focus on on this on
this video
and i can honestly say hand on heart you
know that was put together in in 24
hours and and i get a lot of criticism
when people say oh gosh it's all very
slick and professional and all this i
think professional is a good thing i
think being professional at things is
something that we should celebrate and
actually we need more of it and if we
want to compete in the 21st century then
yes we do need people to be professional
and ambitious and strive to be the best
at what they do i'm not going to
apologize for that and i'm really lucky
i've got some people who are brilliant
at that and that was put together in a
day it's why because it was quite simple
i was just telling the story about my
family and where i grew up and my values
and that's why i want to be prime
minister because this country did
something incredible for my family by
welcoming them here as immigrants 60
years ago they allowed my parents to
build a life for us i worked in my mom's
shop as i said my dad was nhs gp we were
brought up with values of hard work and
public service and family
and it's because of their sacrifice
and kindness and commitment that i had
the opportunities that i had and as
prime minister i want everyone
everyone's kids and grandkids to have
those same opportunities that's a pretty
simple story to tell and that's why it
was possible to do it quickly and all
they did was i didn't even know they
called my parents they got some photos
the first the first time i saw it was a
minute before it went out and that was
it i was actually looking forward to a
nice holiday for the first time
yeah
by his own account um dominic cummings
had long ago conceived the idea that you
should um uh replace boris indeed he
seemed to have thought of it when he
when you went into the treasury in the
first place well that would be a
question for
for dominic cummings to to answer for my
part i ha again this is something that
people will put about which is which is
fine i haven't spoken to dominic
cummings or communicated with him in any
way shape or form since the day he left
downing street that was almost now
coming up on two years ago but the fact
that people still want to put this about
i mean fair enough if they if they want
to try and throw some mud my way that's
okay i haven't spoken to him for almost
two years he wouldn't have anything to
do with any
downing street operation that i was
fortunate enough to to run and there's
not much more i can say about it than
that thank you um
you speak very um
uh
strongly and movingly about your
background and its importance um
this gives you
authority perhaps to talk about
something that you don't actually talk
about very much but increasingly worries
people particularly um
i think conservative supporters which is
everything coming coming under the
slightly annoying word woke
um so um
how do you approach that subject so far
i'd say that without ever
saying woke things you've slightly
sidestepped the subject where would you
where would you tend to
shouldn't you be saying more it seems to
have got more and more salience well i
as as chancellor my main priority was
focusing on the economy and
you talked about loyalty before
i i actually deliberately strived as
chancellor not to talk about things that
were outside of my brief because every
time i did or even remotely did it
everyone would start saying oh gosh well
what does that mean and does that mean
you're interested in being leader one
day right so i actually delivery went
out of my way not to do it and now it's
painted as a criticism as well we didn't
hear enough from you on your views on
education policy or crime or migration
um but it was a deliberate choice on my
part because i didn't want to cause any
trouble um but you're hearing from me
now and i mentioned my
illegal migration video please everyone
watching if you've got five minutes
gonna have a look at it and you'll see
my ten point plan i'm gonna make the
point in there that you know it's not
racist to talk about wanting to control
our borders and you know i do talk
passionately about the fact that this
country did something amazing for my
family you know but my family and
millions like them they followed the
rules and they came here legally yeah
and that's what we need we need a system
that allows for that yeah and when
people are exploiting that and breaking
the rules we should be robust in
defending that and so that's for example
one example
on the broader thing yeah you know look
my view on this is is simple it comes
let's do you know women's issues you
know you mentioned my wife i have two
young daughters and i think their rights
are important i mean of course i know
what a woman is i'm married to one and
i'm gonna be very robust about defending
women's rights whether it comes to
language or changing rooms or sports or
all those types of things and of course
i you know i i fully respect people's
what their right to live how they want
to love who they want but you know
women's rights are also important and i
will robustly defend them do you think i
mean
many people would say
and the person who said it eloquently in
the in the in this context was kemi
basically yes um that there's a sort of
threat to civilization western
civilization here um in wakery do you
agree with that i thought what kemmie
did brilliantly actually in the debates
is
she she linked this this can woke agenda
which we're all familiar with and and
made the argument i think very
forcefully and well that we shouldn't
just view that that force as being
narrowly confined to some of these
cultural issues actually as
conservatives who believe in a smaller
state and a thriving civic society we
should view that same agenda as a threat
to all of those things it's much broader
than the kind of the definition of what
a woman is over here it's that same
force that is actually got a very
different conception of the role between
the state and the individual
and i think kenny made that point i
think articulately and well and it's a
much that we should realize as
conservatives there's a much broader
fight that we've got here on our hands
and look and i'm someone instinctively
i'm not going to cross the road to start
a culture war
but i'm someone who will robustly defend
our values and institutions when they
are under attack
and i know that's the approach i would
take but kemi mate i said made the
excellent point that it's not just these
narrow issues it's much more pervasive
and if you think when i talked about
kids in education
i'm really you know i want to make sure
that what is hap what our kids are being
exposed to in schools
accords with our values and i come and
approach that first and foremost as a
parent part of those depend on
how you understand british history
and as a um as someone of indian
heritage what would you say
about the role historical role of
britain in india what how would you how
do you regard that yeah look you know
it's funny right i'm married also to an
indian citizen and my my in-laws are
indian citizens as opposed to british
indian like me
and
you know i'm i'm not one of these people
who thinks that we should erase our
history and
not be proud of it right in no country's
history is
you know free of blemishes of course
that's right but there's an enormous
amount in our history to be proud of and
we have to accept along the way the
things that were not perfect as well we
should try to raise that we shouldn't
try and focus only on that as well
specifically in relation to india what
do you think of the british uh story
well the british story everyone knows
right and there you know there were many
things that were that were done that
were you know that may have ended up
being beneficial not least language and
other things but of course there were
episodes in it that were appalling and
it didn't mean to say that you know
winston churchill said that when you
talk about things like the amritsar
massacre
no one can say that that was not
anything other than absolutely appalling
as parliament at the time had
commissions and and talked about it and
rightly people should be were at the
time held to account about it and but so
you know of course as a british indian
i'm going to feel that that type of
stuff acutely but i'm very proud of our
history as a country enormously proud of
it this country welcomed me and my
family here and they chose to come here
and i think that's what's different if
you're an immigrant if you remember
my family chose britain because britain
was this unbelievably special place that
represented a set of values and ideals
that appeal to them about fairness about
opportunity about a country where if you
worked hard put in and integrated you
could build a better life for yourself
and that's what britain means to me
and you talk about india now we've we've
got to look forward right yeah so this
goes back to supply side reform and
growth we need to make sure that
actually our our students or both of us
studying in each other's universities
because there's as much that we can
learn there as as we can attract indian
students here are our companies
developing products and services
together is capital flowing between our
economies and we saw that on the vaccine
for example an extraordinary
collaboration between british and indian
research and manufacturing that's what
the future of that relationship looks
like and i gave a speech on this a few
weeks ago yes um
you know that that's something that we
should all be optimistic about i'm
conscious of of time but right but just
one thing that flows on from that is
do you know are you not the first
generation of british politicians who
face the fact that the the west
dominance uh is really under threat um
for the first time in uh since the
second world war arguably for much much
longer than that actually um and um
this makes everything different so for
example in the case of russia's attack
on ukraine um
china is basically against us on this um
and actually india isn't really for us
either it sort of holds
holes back it's not very friendly to us
about that and lots of smaller states
are not necessarily helping us helping
the west on this issue in
international forums and so on um
do you think that that we face a crisis
in the west
which our leaders are not really facing
up to
primarily but not only because of the
massive threat of china
yes i think china is a significant
threat to us and
you know i talked about it yesterday
it's a threat to our economic security
and thereby our national security and we
need to be robust in defending ourselves
against that
i think you're right i think we you know
i think there is a complacency about
this and i've worked and lived around
the world
and i mentioned it in the maze lecture
you know our ability to project power
and influence and to make a difference
in the difference in the world is is in
large part a function of the strength of
our economy
and you know ultimately if we want to
fund the armed forces if we want to make
sure that we can make a difference in
countries around the world it all starts
with having a very strong vibrant
growing economy which is why getting
that right is critical to all these
things because there's only so much we
can rely on
history and nostalgia to project our
power we need actually raw power and
that comes
first of all from economic strength now
the the thing i see and it goes back to
the debate in this leadership election
is are we prepared to work at it or not
right are we prepared to do what all
these other countries are doing which is
have a time horizon that is far longer
than ours they are all prepared to
sacrifice in the short term yeah because
they want to do something that in their
it advances their interests in the long
term they are prepared to sacrifice they
are prepared to work hard you sought you
see all that in china you see that you
see it in russia right they prepared for
this for a very long time right and
we have to ask ourselves are we prepared
to do the same can we look forward to
richie soon at built-in road initiative
yeah well well that's
well our economic strength is important
to making sure that we can counter
initiatives like that but it's all that
our military strength can be projected
but i think there's something more
fundamental we have to have the hunger
that we have no right to a seat at that
top table we have no right to project
our force and our values more
importantly across the world we have to
earn it
and the things that are worth having
require hard work and sacrifice but i
tell you they are sweeter as a result uh
but it's an entirely conservative value
i think to to sacrifice in the short
term as my family did for a very
different reason to put in the hard work
to build a better future and if we want
to meet these threats from countries
like china from russia and others
we need to get ourselves into that
mindset as a country so these arguments
that i'm making in a micro sense on
taxing and borrowing uh can actually be
expanded to a much larger thing are we
prepared to earn the success that we
need in order to succeed in the world
and that is a critical question right
and it's not easy for people to hear
that and as as leader it's my
responsibility to get our country in a
position to do that thank you one very
quick class question um you praised mrs
satcher but you probably don't like this
quotation um
um particularly because you are up
against a strong woman and she said um
the cox may crow but the hen lays the
eggs
what do you
how do you react to that well you know
what i i i'm a dad first and foremost
regardless of this job i'm the dad of
two young girls so the more amazing
female role models they have uh the
better i think there was a lovely story
i can't remember it was in your book or
was it in one of hers where she was
visiting a school at some point a
primary school somewhere in the late 80s
and uh she was asking the kids it was a
boy about you know what did he want to
do when he grew up and i can't remember
what he said and then she said
and then she said oh do you not want to
be prime minister and he said oh can
boys do that
and i thought that was brilliant right
so
uh yeah you know as a dad of two young
girls you know i said but this boy can
do it this boy can do it against a woman
right
you're talking about me yes yes
absolutely i can yes absolutely i can
and look you've seen great female role
models in this campaign whether it's
kemi whether it's penny whether it's uh
whether it's liz but you know i believe
i'm the right person to do this job at
this time we have enormous challenges
facing the country you know i will bring
a different type of leadership and it's
leadership that will make sure that we
are fit for the future and i'm doing
this motivated by a set of conservative
values that i hold dear that i am
passionate about that i was raised with
because of what this country did for my
family that's what i will bring to this
office and we will deliver a
conservative government that makes an
enormous difference to people's lives mr
tsunami thank you very much thank you
charles